FAREED ZAKARIA: We are now
living in a totally new era.
That is what the
99-year-old Henry
Kissinger said commenting on
Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
In an op ed article last
week, President Biden
vividly outlined the stakes.
He wrote, "if Russia does
not pay a heavy price
for its actions, it
will send a message
to other would-be
aggressors that they
too can seize territory and
subjugate other countries.
It will put the survival of
other peaceful democracies
at risk, and it
could mark the end
of the rules-based
international order
and open the door to
aggression elsewhere
with catastrophic
consequences the world over."
In times like these,
it seemed appropriate
that the secretary of
state, Antony Blinken,
would deliver a major
policy address, which he did
late last month,
except that he chose
to give the talk on China.
The speech itself
contained nothing new.
It was slightly more
nuanced than the usual chest
thumping that passes for a
China strategy these days.
The real surprise was
that in the middle
of the first major land
war in Europe since 1945
with monumental consequences,
Blinken would not
lay out the strategy for
victory, but instead,
changed the subject.
Washington's foreign policy
establishment is so wrapped up
in its pre-crisis thinking
that it cannot really digest
the fact that the
ground has shifted
seismically under its feet.
Blinken declared that despite
its aggression in Ukraine,
Russia does not pose
the greatest threat
to the rules-based
international order,
instead giving that
place to China.
As Zachary Karabell
suggests, this
requires a willful
blindness to two
decades of Russian aggression.
Russia has invaded
Georgia and Ukraine
and effectively annexed
parts of those countries.
It brutally unleashed
its air power in Syria,
killing thousands of civilians.
In responding to Chechnya's
desire for independence,
it flattened large parts
of the Russian republic,
including its capital, with
total civilian casualties
in that conflict estimated in
the tens of thousands at least.
Putin has sent assassination
squads to Western countries
to kill his enemies, has
used money and cyber attacks
to disrupt Western
democracies, and most recently,
has threatened the use
of nuclear weapons.
Does any other country
even come close?
Ironically, one of the people
who attended Blinken's speech
was Senator Mitt Romney,
who, during his presidential
campaign in 2012, warned that
Russia posed the single largest
threat to the United States.
MITT ROMNEY: Without
question, our number one
geopolitical foe.
FAREED ZAKARIA: Those,
including myself,
who dismissed his
prognosis were wrong
because we looked only
at Russia's strength,
which was not impressive.
But Romney clearly
understood that power
in the international realm
is measured by a mixture
of capabilities and intentions.
And while Russia is
not a rising giant,
it is determined to challenge
and divide America and Europe
and tear up the rules-based
international system.
Putin's Russia is the
world's great spoiler state.
This phenomenon of
a declining power
becoming the greatest
danger to global peace
is not unprecedented.
In 1914, The country
that triggered World War
I was Austria-Hungary, an empire
in broad decline and yet one
determined to use its military
to show the world it still
mattered and to
teach a harsh lesson
to Serbia, which it regarded
as a minor vassal state.
Sounds familiar?
America's dominant
priority must be
to ensure that Russia does
not prevail in its aggression
against Ukraine.
And right now, trends are
moving in the wrong direction.
Russian forces are consolidating
their gains in eastern Ukraine.
Sky-high oil prices have
ensured that money continues
to flow into Putin's coffers.
Europeans are beginning
to talk about off ramps.
Moscow is offering
developing nations a deal--
get the West to call off
sanctions, it tells them,
and it will help export all the
grain from Ukraine and Russia
and avert famine in
many parts of the world.
Ukraine's leaders
say it still does not
have the weapons and
training it needs
to fight back effectively.
The best China strategy
right now, by the way,
is to defeat Russia.
Xi Jinping has
made a risky wager
in backing Russia so strongly
on the eve of the invasion.
If Russia comes out
of this conflict
a weak, marginalized
country, that
will be a serious
blow to President
Xi, who is personally associated
with this alliance with Putin.
If, on the other hand, Putin
survives and somehow manages
to stage a comeback, Xi and
China will learn an ominous
lesson that the West cannot
uphold its rules-based system
against a sustained assault.
Most of the people in top
positions in the Biden
administration were senior
officials in the Obama
administration in
2014 when Russia
launched its first invasion
of Ukraine, annexed Crimea,
and intervened in
eastern Ukraine.
They were not able to
reverse Moscow's aggression
or even make Putin pay
much of a price for it.
Perhaps at the time, they
saw the greatest threat
to global order as
ISIS or al-Qaeda,
or they were focused
on the pivot to Asia,
or they didn't prioritize
Ukraine enough.
Well, now they have
a second chance,
but it is likely to be the last.